en allemagne de l'est de la saison de la
chasse aux profiteurs et ouverte hier
c'est toute la direction de la police
politique qui a démissionné en bloc il
ya également un homme de confiance de
l'ancien président est allé chez necker
a été appréhendé on l'accuse non
seulement de trafic d'armes et de
devises de chantage et on assiste
actuellement un spectacle incroyable
parti communiste et l'opposition
rivalisent pour dénoncer les
malversations
jérôme baugnies et roger motte ont
enquêté dans la banlieue de berne est où
ils ont rencontré un incorruptible un
membre du nouveau forum le mouvement
d'opposition en rp a aujourd'hui en
allemagne de l'est il y a encore des
murs des murs entre allemands de l'est
et allemands de l'est
celui ci avant de l'it au nord de berlin
entoure une zone résidentielle au luxe
occidental habitée par des cadres du
parti pas question de passer la grille
sans autorisation
van cleef ou erich honecker est
aujourd'hui en résidence surveillée
reste le symbole de privilèges bien
protégé
partout en rda il ya des ventes dit mais
aujourd'hui la chasse aux privilèges et
ouverte à riau feu producteur de rock et
militant du nouveau forum part en guerre
contre la corruption dans sa commune
devenue près de berlin
il se bat maintenant au grand jour et
vient de saisir la justice à propos
d'une résidence qui considèrent comme
suspect la plupart des villages sont
habités par des agents de l'ex stasi la
police politique celle qui fit
emprisonner son beau père pendant quatre
ans et demi
il ya un problème dans l'attribution des
logements
les habitants de l'aude soupçonné ici un
deuxième bande vite et des privilèges
non justifiées
il avait demandé une enquête mais est ce
que aujourd'hui vous ne craignez pas
encore la stasi non si maintenant une
stasi quelconque reprenez le sceptre ce
ne serait pas des centaines de milliers
mais des millions de gens qui
descendraient dans la rue quelque chose
que nous n'accepterons pas de nous
il y a deux mois le maire considère et
harry comme un hors-la-loi participant à
des réunions clandestines
aujourd'hui il le reçoit répond à ces
questions sur les habitants des villes
là et affirme qu'il fera tout pour les
faire déguerpir
les verts se retourne
dans les bars les commentaires sont
désabusés
depuis 40 ans les citoyens ont travaillé
pour l'état sans penser médoc au
contraire notamment dans le parti se
sont permis de faire passer leurs
intérêts en priorité sans penser aux
travailleurs
comme arnaud partout dans le pays des
enquêtes sont lancés la justice saisie
mais aujourd'hui encore en rda personne
n'a confiance en personne